so first of all I loved the film and
really really enjoyed it was so funny
one of the main things that I loved
about it was the whole nostalgia naughty
smile star Jennifer yeah so with that
being said I've got a little nostalgic
quiz for all Sarah and 2002 at the film
so I'm gonna ask any questions okay but
Dory's multiple choice so it's multiple
choice okay so sheriff right now so
first one is what was the biggest film
of the year spider-man or Lord of the
Rings the two towers it this is in 2002
yeah in 2002 like what are in the most
money yeah it has to be Lord of the
Rings no it was fine I think yeah I
woulda said I was really surprised
mmm she chairs is my favorite one every
day my rings yeah what was the biggest
song yeah
so Nickelback how you remind me or
Nellie horn here what's the Nickelback
on how you remind me how you remind me I
don't know what that one is so I'm gonna
say it's Nelly the other one what I feel
is like a really big but I thought was
nerdy as well to be fair I was wrong I
was also a child from all this is gone
may I am you two so yeah we should
probably know the MALDI it fair well
sure however not me which Disney
animated Kazakh was released in 2002 you
lilo and Stitch or Finding Nemo I'd say
they were they were released around the
same time probably this isn't a trick
question but okay both of them is mad
I'm like okay I'm just gonna pick lilo
and Stitch yeah I'm really good yes who
won Best Actress at the Oscars was it
Halle Berry or Nicole Kidman from
offense no why do have what films don't
me to help you out I think you I think
it was probably Halle Berry yeah yeah
yeah which Harry Potter film was for
these different chambers okay
Oh prison of Azkaban it would have been
it would have been chamber of secrets
yeah okay
great let's see
which of these was an actual fashion
trend in 2002 was it wearing trousers
with one lick rolled up and one down
okay or wearing your top back to front
was that the tracer thing yeah I am
exceptional at this I'm getting a little
puffy now which a-list celeb couple
broke up with shattered or the dream
about now is there multiple choice was
it yeah was it Justin and Britney or P
Diddy and Jade oh oh I feel like Justin
and Britney probably would have split up
earlier
okay thank you I thought I was like you
were gonna say Brad and Jen oh oh no was
it I don't know don't know that was a
shocker that was Ross I got that who
performed at the Super Bowl
u2 or Prince YouTube yeah yeah okay well
well tiny one okay no I got that one
woohoo you would the prize of winning
okay so back to the film yeah and we're
just someone talk about stealing a
little bit she's obviously such an
outgoing character she kind of she's got
this confidence about her and she just
kind of just does what she wants yeah
what would you describe yourself like at
her age at hurry
yes um I I was pretty sure myself I
think I probably was pretty similar to
how I am now I feel like I was probably
about like 45 from 16 years old and I'm
just like age and into that yeah um so I
think I was probably like an old woman
when I was 17 anyway and I wasn't as
rebellious as Lady Bird was but I really
liked
I mean it's unbasic aliy exactly the
same now I just really like listening to
kind of older music and stuff and
was working a lot and and yeah and you
go through that stage or kind of being
like will they ever find my people like
the people that I didn't a fight with
them stuff and of course you do but and
that was probably around that time yeah
obviously later buds pair it's like her
signature look and other people have
dyed their hair that color in a yes
trendsetter did you dye your actual her
I did a vertical maybe I loved it but I
chopped you ever to come in to come out
really yeah was it like a struggle was
it is it factor no no or does it it's
been so many colors in the last like
five weeks allow really oh yeah I've got
a platinum blonde yeah - to know did
help fund again yeah oh and looking back
at your own teenagers did you have your
own like signature look would you say or
was there something that you kind of
made your own I think when I was a
younger teenager I always loved my jeans
I always used to wear a lot of
bell-bottoms and say old woman bottoms
and like cool sort of hippie shirts and
things like that but then as I got a
little bit older I grew up in the
countryside so everyone like boys and
girls just wore the same clothes we just
all wore tracksuit bottoms hoodies
trainers and just like casual wear yeah
which was quite close actually because
there wasn't like anyone
there's nobody compared and them to what
yeah that is pretty nice it was good
yeah obviously you travel a lot and I'm
sure you're always on planes and stuff
do you have any skincare products that
you use on planes usually just for
whatever is in the little bag though the
ones that you get trying to cleanse but
I love them ease up enough that I don't
their stuff it's about a ESO P so you
think it's a yourself that it's actually
easy yeah I had great well thank you so
much for talking to me thank you and
good luck at
thanks for letting me win the quiz
you